WALEED KADOUS: OK, thank
you very much.
We're really excited that
you've joined us today.
My name is Waleed Kadous, and
next to me is Sarah Peterson,
the Business Product Manager
for Indoor Maps.
And we're really excited to talk
to you today about Indoor
Maps and their potential to make
people's lives a little
less tedious, a little less
annoying, so they can get on
with what they really want to
get on about and do whatever
it is that they want to do,
just as Larry mentioned in
today's keynote.
So here's what we want to plan
to talk about today.
We want to tell you why we think
indoors are important,
and now is a critical time
for Indoor Maps.
We want to walk you through what
we have right now, what
the state of the current product
is, where we're up to.
And then we want to take you a
little bit behind the curtain
of how we made Indoor
Maps, how they work.
And we're going to share some
stuff with you today that we
haven't shared publicly before,
and that's what we're
really excited about as well,
and we look forward to your
questions and answers.
And finally, we want to
discuss with you, as
developers, some of the exciting
opportunities we
think are coming for Indoor
Location and Indoor Maps.
So why do we care about
Indoor Maps so much?
So here's the first reason.
According to the EPA,
people spend 90%
of their time indoors.
And some of you might
say, well, what's
the point of that?
Half of that is me sleeping in
bed, and the other half is
when I'm at work.
But when you actually look at
where people spend, and you
just focus on public
indoor spaces--
places like restaurants, places
like Moscone Center
right now--
those types of places, they
spend about an hour, hour and
a half in shopping and all
of those kinds of things.
Now just as Larry mentioned
today, by comparison, people
spend about 50 minutes every day
outdoors or commuting and
just getting from
place to place.
Yet we've devoted a huge amount
of our efforts to this
application that works in the
outdoor case, but we haven't
really spent a lot of time
on the indoor case.
And I want to tell you a little
bit more just to give
you an idea of how present
Indoors can be.
So I want you to think about
what it's like for people in
Tokyo, and here's, actually, a
story that happened to me.
I went to visit Google's office
in Roppongi Hills,
which is a beautiful,
beautiful office.
I checked into the hotel,
the Grand Hyatt.
I went downstairs, had breakfast
in their cafe.
I went to Google's office, and
if you guys ever get the
opportunity to visit the Google
office there in Tokyo,
it's an amazing, amazing
office with
views of Mount Fuji.
And then some of my other
colleagues at Google decided
it was time for us to go out and
get some food for dinner.
And sure enough, we hopped
on the train.
We changed trains twice, and
then we ended up at this
beautiful, beautiful sushi
restaurant where we had some
pretty nice food.
And the amazing thing to me
about that entire trip is I
wasn't outdoors once.
I was indoors the entire time.
And that's what it's like to
live in a place like Tokyo or
Singapore or one of those
other urbanized centers.
And if you can't provide
information to people in that
kind of environment about how
to go about their daily
business, then you're
not really
delivering a great service.
So I want to focus on a few
particular classes and ways
that we can use Indoor Maps to
make people's experiences
easier and to get the
inconvenient questions out of
their lives.
The first is that we can enhance
existing products.
You can imagine if we can answer
questions like, is
there an ATM inside here, or I
need to find the restrooms
quickly, those types of things,
we can really remove a
lot of the annoyance
in people's lives.
But there's another class of
applications that's not
foreground applications like
this, where the user comes to
you and asks a question.
Those are background
applications, what we would
call contextual apps, and we
really think there's a lot of
potential there for Indoor Maps
and Location to enhance
the performance on that
particular front.
And I'm going to come back to
that at the end of the session
just to kind of point you as we
look forward to what we can
do with that.
All right.
So let's take a deep dive.
Let's say you buy my story and
you agree that Indoor Maps are
really very useful.
Let's just do a deep dive, find
out what the different
components are.
So on the left here, you can see
what it looks like before
we add Indoor Maps to a venue,
and on the right here, you can
see what we end up
with afterwards.
You can see we've added
a lot more detail.
There's the Floor Selector
over here.
You've noticed that the blue
dot and the blue circle are
strengthened.
So you can see that there's
a lot of work
that goes into this.
This happens to be the Mall of
America, which is the biggest
mall in the United States.
It's so big there's a theme
park in the middle, and in
wintertime, runners run around
the loop because it's too cold
to go running outside.
And if you were in that type of
venue, can you imagine if
you didn't have Indoor Maps if
you wanted to find someone?
Four levels of just retail after
retail after retail.
You can see how valuable having
indoor information is.
Let's zoom in for a moment
just to kind of see.
So as well as the big picture,
you have the other
information.
Over here, you have
the restrooms.
You have information desk.
You have elevators
and escalators.
All of that's got to be added.
And what's interesting is those,
what we call points of
interest, vary from
place to place.
If you're at an airport, what
you care about is the airport
baggage carousels.
If you're in a museum, you care
about the displays and
the exhibitions.
And if you're in a department
store, you care about men's
shoes or whatever else it is
that you're looking for.
And as well as that, you need
to know the walking paths so
we can give you really
high-quality
directions as well.
But there's another component
as well as the map, which we
call a location, of course, and
here's the tricky part.
Maps don't really become that
useful if you don't know where
you are relative to them.
And we really care a lot about
user location and getting the
user's location as accurate
as possible.
So this is a screenshot from
the Bloomingdale's that's
around the corner or across the
road from here, where we
have Indoor Maps and Indoor
location, and I just wanted to
give you a feel of the different
error metrics.
So this circle shows about
25-meter accuracy.
So 25 meters, 30 meters, roughly
speaking, that's what
you get from a network-based
location.
So you can see it's not really
very useful to the user.
He could be in one of four
different departments.
He could be in women's
fragrances or cosmetics.
We just don't have a clue.
So if you just showed this
circle to the user, it
wouldn't be very useful.
Now here's the interesting
thing.
Let's go to 15 meters, and
that's a little bit better.
We're starting to work out maybe
they're only in one of
three different departments.
Now, here's something I
want you to notice.
15 meters is about what
you get with GPS.
So what I want you to realize
is that the error levels for
Location and Indoors
are even higher.
And it's only when you get to
5-ish, 10-ish meters that you
start to get useful.
You can identify right
away where you are.
And at the 6-meter level, it
varies a lot from place to
place what accuracy
levels we get.
But roughly speaking, 6 meters
is kind of the mean of the
performance when we do
high-quality location.
And of course, our goal is to
get to 1 meter, at which point
you can really, really
accurately place yourself and
you can help the user find
what they need to find.
So I really want to tell you why
I'm excited to be talking
to you today.
It's really about these four
things that are coming
together right at this
very moment.
Google now has some
really, really
good indoor maps coverage.
In fact, imagine we took all
of our indoor maps, all of
them, and tiled them end to
end, you'd have enough to
cover the entire city
of San Francisco.
And in fact, not just that, but
you'd need a pretty decent
mezzanine, almost an entire
other floor to really show
what the extent of our coverage
is, and we're going
to keep adding San
Francisco-sized floors as we
move forward.
Not only that, but there's the
possibility of adding the
high-quality indoor location,
as I mentioned.
Combine that with self-service
tools that allow people like
business owners and venue owners
to upload Location and
Indoor Maps, as well as
improving developer APIs, and
I have to ask the question,
are we getting close to a
tipping point on Indoor Maps?
And let me be clear what I
mean by a tipping point.
So maybe some of you are old
enough to remember 1999, that
between 1999 and 2003, there
was this really weird
transition that happened
to the web.
If you found a company or a
business, and you searched for
them on the web, and you found
they had a web page, you'd be
like, cool.
That company is kind of
ahead of the curve.
And then by 2003, what happened
was you found a
business or company, you looked
for their website, and
if they didn't have one,
you'd be like,
what's wrong with them?
Why aren't they keeping
up with the times?
And in fact, it's borne
out by the statistics.
I took the statistics for the
growth of domain name
registrations between
1999 and 2003.
And whap, in the space of
four years, domain name
registrations grew by a factor
of 33, which is incredible.
And what I'm wondering is, is
Indoors on the verge of the
same thing?
We have all of the
prerequisites.
Will we go to a place where
you open Google Maps on
Android right now, and you see
floor plans for Moscone and
you go, ooh, that's
kind of cool.
But going to a business
somewhere, and then all of a
sudden, you pull out your phone,
and they don't have a
map and you'll be like, what's
wrong with this business?
Why don't they have
Indoor Maps?
And I think we may be on the
cusp of that very, very
exciting transition.
So you guys are like, well yeah,
I mean, he's preaching
to the converted.
Why don't we have
this already?
I wanted to spend a few minutes
to explain to you the
challenges that we face as we
try to really move the needle
on Indoor Maps.
So the first problem you have is
where do you get your floor
plans from?
When you're outdoors, let's say
that you wanted to do maps
for the entire US.
You can actually go to the US
Census, and there's this
really nice data set called
Tiger, and it has road names,
and address ranges, and the
geography, and the layout, and
the suburbs, and the cities, a
huge amount of information.
But that information doesn't
exist indoors in the same way.
And as well as that, we
don't even have the
means to verify it.
So as we'll talk about-- and
there'll be a presentation
after this about
Ground Truth--
we use Street View and aerial
imagery to really get the
quality of our outdoor maps up,
so it's going to be hard
to do that.
The second thing is that
location is very challenging.
As we mentioned, the first
problem is that you've got a
higher bar to meet.
Just bringing GPS indoors, even
if you could do it, would
not be good enough, and
that's the problem.
GPS doesn't work indoors, and
I think users don't realize
that this is the case.
But if you were to pull out a
phone right now, you'd get the
blinking GPS sign, and you'd
probably get it all day
because the satellites just
can't get in here.
So you can't use GPS, and one of
the worst things about GPS
is you can't estimate elevation
very accurately.
So we're going to have to
come up with some other
technologies that help
us to determine which
level someone is on.
And some of you who know your
sensors on the phones are
saying, well, we could use
the barometer, right?
That's a really, really
accurate sensor.
In fact, if you have a phone
and you open the barometer,
you'll see that the barometers
are kind of awesome.
They can tell the difference
in elevation between this
height and this height
quite easily.
So you go, great.
That's awesome.
All we need to do is measure
out a difference of 0.4
hectopascals, which is what the
units of air pressure are,
and we're golden.
We can just use that and
estimate the elevation.
But there's a problem.
So if you go down the coast to
Half Moon Bay and you take the
air pressure measurements,
remember how I said it was 0.4
hectopascals?
This is the natural variation
that occurs in air pressure.
So let me recalibrate this
graph for you in terms of
floors, and you can see that
just the natural air pressure
variation is plus or minus 24.
So you've got to do some really
clever processing just
to estimate your elevation.
And this is just an example of
why we face challenges with
determination of location.
So we've kind of outlined some
of the potential benefits, why
we think we're especially
excited, how we can use Indoor
Maps to help people,
and why it's hard.
But now let's actually do a deep
dive into the technology
as we show you what
we have so far.
And with that, I'll hand
it over to Sarah.
SARAH PETERSON: Thank
you, Waleed.
So before I get started, how
many of guys have actually
used Indoor Maps today, just
a quick show of hands?
Cool.
And how many of you guys
actually used Indoor Maps on
your journey to I/O?
So for those if you were out
of town or not out of town?
About maybe five.
All right, cool.
WALEED KADOUS: It's kind
of low numbers.
SARAH PETERSON: So hopefully,
more of you will be convinced
to use it on your way home.
So I'm going to do a quick demo
of SFO and then talk a
little bit about what
we have today.
Hopefully, a few of you at least
were traveling through
San Francisco International
Airport, or SFO, as I'll call
it, over the past
couple of days.
So the first thing to notice
with our Indoor Maps is that
what we want to do is we want
to make sure that we map all
of the public space
within a venue.
So for SFO, this means all of
the terminals as well as that
middle circle, which
is a parking lot.
And as we dive in here, you're
going to see that the next
important thing is
that we want to--
WALEED KADOUS: What
happened there?
SARAH PETERSON: Bummer.
WALEED KADOUS: There we go.
Let's give that a try.
Look good?
SARAH PETERSON: So, of course,
we want to make sure that we
get all of the important
attributes within a venue.
So within an airport, that's
going to mean things like the
ticket counters, which you can
see here, the bathrooms.
As I scroll over, you can see in
the middle are the security
checkpoints.
You're obviously going to want
to know where your gate is if
you're at an airport.
And on the right-hand side,
you're going to see what
Waleed mentioned briefly, but
that's the Level Selector.
So within the international
terminal, you can see there
are actually four levels,
and I can easily
move between these.
And of course, when I'm in
international, the big--
bummer.
The big dark piece is not
actually public space since
you're coming into the US,
so that's grayed out.
And you'll see as I move over
to Terminal Three, there are
only three floors within
Terminal Three.
Go down to Level One, you can
actually see the baggage
carousels for United
in this case.
So now, let's just run through
a quick use case to show what
you guys can actually do with
Indoor Maps at the airport.
WALEED KADOUS: Should we switch
to the WolfVision?
SARAH PETERSON: Yeah, we
can do WolfVision.
It's been a rough day with
the demo gods for
Google, I would say.
Perfect.
So I tend to fly really early
in the mornings, when I'm
flying out of SFO, what do I
want when I get to the airport
at 6:00 AM?
I usually want a coffee.
And so I'm just going to go
in and search for coffee.
And what this is going to do is
it's going to bring up all
of the coffee shops
that are actually
within this indoor venue.
So I can scroll around
on the left-hand side
and see what's available.
Alternatively, I can just
browse within the venue.
You notice that the Level
Selector is now actually
annotated with a little red
dot to show you on which
levels a coffee shop exists.
So I can see that not only on
the second level, which I'm on
right now, are there
coffee shops.
If I click on three, there's
a pizza up here
on the third floor.
This is a bit of a bummer.
Well, we'll run through
this quickly.
Both those coffee shops look
like they're before security.
I don't like to chug
my coffee.
I don't think anybody does.
So I'm going to select
this Peet's Coffee.
If I was actually at SFO right
now, what I would do is I
would simply click on Go, and
it would give me indoor
directions from where I was
standing to the Peet's Coffee.
Since we're at Moscone,
we're going to cheat.
I'm just going to click
a point on the map.
The wireless is a little
flaky here.
We might bail out to
the slides here.
Yeah, bummer.
Let's just roll.
The beauty of not having demos
work is that you can always go
back to the slides.
So the cool thing that I want
to show you guys is that we
actually have great indoor
navigation between levels.
So if search for coffee, it's
going to bring up all these
different coffee shops.
I select the Peet's Coffee.
We can actually navigate you.
So say I got dropped off on
the first floor where the
taxis drop me off.
We can actually now navigate
you between levels.
And so it's going to tell me to
walk over to the escalator,
to take the escalator up to the
second floor right here,
and then it navigates me
right to the Peet's,
which is pretty sweet.
And we can do this in much more
complex venues than this.
So we launched Indoor Maps in
2011 in the US and Japan.
Since then, we've added 11
additional markets, including
three just in the last
three months.
So most recently, we've launched
Spain, Singapore, as
well as Australia.
As Waleed mentioned, we're
excited about adding more over
the next year.
Within each of these countries,
we're really
focused on big, public, complex
venues where we can
help you guys navigate around.
So take a minute and imagine
that you're here.
This is Shinjuku Station
in Tokyo.
It's the world's busiest
passenger train station.
Maybe you want to find
your platform.
So actually, I was here
a few years ago.
I used to live in Japan,
I took this
actually on a Saturday.
So this isn't even rush
hour at Shinjuku.
I mean, Shinjuku gets crazy.
What we can actually do, a big
focus for us has been on
really expanding the number of
transit stations that we
provide Indoor Maps on.
This is actually giving you
platform-to-platform
directions.
And so you can go from a point
outside of Shinjuku.
We will direct you, navigate
you right to your platform,
and then even tell you what
platform you're getting off at
in Shibuya, which is where
I chose to navigate to.
So in addition to transit
stations, we've had a big
focus on retail and malls.
So this is the ION Mall
in Singapore.
It's right off of Orchard
Road, for those
familiar with Singapore.
This is the first floor, and
it shows all of the normal
shops and whatnot.
But what's really cool about
this mall is that it goes four
floors underground.
You can see that we've
mapped all of
these underground levels.
For those that have been to
Singapore, you might know that
it's pretty hot, and there's
a pretty big mall culture.
You don't really like to go
outside if you can avoid it to
some extent.
You can actually see within this
mall that you can cross
underground.
And so instead of going out to
cross the street to go to the
mall next door, I can actually
just navigate in that little
bit to the top left.
I can see that it goes
underneath the road.
And then right above
it, that's actually
the mall next door.
So I can navigate myself from
one mall to the next
underground using our << maps.
And then just to show the
breadth, this is the same
mall, the ION Mall
in Singapore.
It's a multiuse venue.
There are a bunch of apartment
buildings in the middle.
But on the 55th floor, there's
a sky bar, and we've also
modeled that.
We try to be very,
very complete
with what we're doing.
Here's my favorite venue.
So this is the Smithsonian
National Air and
Space Museum in DC.
So the really cool thing about
this venue is that it's all
about the airplanes.
So what you're going to see here
is that we've actually
gone in and drawn all of the
airplanes within this museum,
because that's where you're
going to navigate to.
So say you're trying to find the
Spirit of St. Louis, which
I've called out on the
top right there.
It's really easy for you to find
that on the second floor
using these maps.
It's just kind of pretty, too.
As Waleed mentioned today, we
also have really high-quality
indoor location.
So this is looking at San
Francisco International
Airport again before
we had Indoor Maps.
You can see how big
that error is.
And then on the right-hand side
after we had Indoor Maps,
how that error bar really
shrinks down, so you can
actually see where you are
within the terminal.
Of course, all this is available
today on Android as
well as on desktop, just for a
single floor right now, and
then through the Google
Maps Android API v2.
So hopefully at this point,
you guys are interested in
understanding a little bit more
about how this works.
So now we want to run you guys
through exactly how we build
this stuff out.
It's a two-part process.
I'm going to start with maps,
and then Waleed's going to
talk a little bit
about location.
Of course, step one is that we
actually need to create an
indoor map of venue.
And to create an indoor
map of the venue, we
actually need to get maps.
So there are two ways
that we do this.
For the bigger venues, we'll
actually go out and directly
partner to actually get
their floor plans.
We also have a tool, the Google
Maps Floor Plans tool,
where anyone can come and upload
a floor plan for their
venue for us to add
to our maps.
So go to
maps.google.com/floorplans,
you click on Add a
Floor Plan Now.
Search for your building within
the tool, drop the
marker on top.
We're using Google Building
43 as our example here.
You then give us a little bit
of additional detail about
your building as well as upload
the actual floor plan
for a particular level, and
you can upload one level.
It would be great if you
uploaded every level for your
building to make things
really complete.
And then once you've uploaded
the floor plan, we ask you to
align it to satellite imagery to
the building footprint that
is shown here.
Once you do that, you simply hit
Accept and Submit, and our
team is going to go
and make sure that
it's a public venue--
we don't want to map
private venues--
as well as that the floor
plan is of high quality.
We're then going to trace your
maps and actually push them
live on Google Maps.
So what you're seeing here,
we're back at the Smithsonian
because it's so cool.
But we're going to go in, and
we're going to trace the
outline of your building.
We're going to trace and draw
all of the interesting
attributes within
your building.
We're going to add things like
water fountains, and
bathrooms, and shops, and
whatever is interesting within
that indoor space, and publish
this live on our maps.
And I highly recommend, if you
guys are interested in how we
actually build out maps, Waleed
already talked about
this for a second, but there's
a really awesome talk right
after this in Room Nine.
And they will show you more
about how these tools work and
exactly how we build out our
maps in Google Earth.
WALEED KADOUS: Thank you
very much, Sarah.
So there are always two
parts to this, right?
There's the maps and there's
the location.
So let's dive into the
location side.
So before I mentioned, and in
these coming slides, I'm going
to refer to what I call
high-quality indoor location
versus normal quality.
Maybe the best way to start is
with a demonstration of that.
So what I'm going to show you
now is, again, I didn't think
this level particularly.
This is just the Bloomingdale's
immediately behind us.
So let me just zoom out,
and what we have
here is normal quality.
The yellow dot here, that's our
estimate based on normal
quality, and the green dot
is Ground Truth's.
So Google sent someone out to
actually tell us where they
were walking, and this is
our estimate if we use
normal-quality location
indoors.
And let's actually
see how it works.
So it kind of follows at
the beginning, but it
jumps around a lot.
And then as the user comes down
to the second half of the
building, it doesn't
really follow them.
But if you actually do the math
on this, this is about
25-meter level accuracy.
You can see it's not doing a
very good job of following the
user in the sense that if
someone is looking at a map,
the user is there, he pulls out
his phone, and he's like,
where am on this map?
It's not very useful.
It just seems to linger
near the entrance.
Now let's actually look what
happens after we've applied
high-quality indoor location.
Again, just to emphasize here,
yellow is our estimate based
on high-quality indoor
location, and
green is Ground Truth.
And you'll see here now that it
still has its flaws, it's
not perfect.
It seems to be out by about
6 or 7 meters here.
But very quickly, you'll see it
does a pretty good job of
following the user around.
And so if you were the user,
this would be much, much, much
more useful.
If you were looking for fitting
rooms or something
like that, you could use
this a lot more easily.
So the question then is, how
is it that we actually get
these high-quality indoor
location models?
And just to highlight this,
I think in the keynote you
remember Hugo Barra
talked about the
Fused Location Provider.
These results are using that
Fused Location Provider that
mixes us all of the sensors
on the phone together.
So what we actually have is we
have a tool called Google Maps
Floor Plan Markup.
That's an app.
You can just search for it on
the web, grab it, and download
it, and install it.
And let's say that you had
uploaded a floor plan, as
Sarah had outlined in the
previous stage, and it had
been approved.
Then as a second, optional
step, you can do the
normal-quality location.
It will still kind of work.
But it won't give you a levels,
and it won't give you
that high accuracy.
So what we do is you can then,
as an optional second step,
help the process by gathering
location.
So this shows the floor plan
that you uploaded in this
particular case, yet another
one of Google's buildings.
And then what happens is you
move this circle around until
it shows where you are.
You hit this marker over here
down on the bottom, and then
that drops a point.
And then what we ask you to do
is to walk through the level,
basically marking where you've
been, and traverse the entire
level, leaving a snail
trail behind.
And we use that information to
then build that high-quality
indoor location model.
Now, a few things I want to
highlight about this.
This is the self-service
model.
For more complicated and not
quite as detailed and even
more detailed venues, actually,
Google has its own
team that it sends out
with a professional
version of this tool.
But one thing I also wanted
to highlight is the
data that we collect.
So we collect a variety of
sensors, but we do collect
Wi-Fi, especially the BSSID
and the RSSI, but we don't
collect SSIDs and we
don't collect data.
And if you're interested in
actually reading the source
code that's at the heart of
the collection of this
algorithm, that's available.
If you look on code.google.com
under Sensor Data Collection
Library, you should be
able to find it.
So what happens is that you
basically go through your
venue, labeling where you are
against landmarks in the floor
plan, and then you
do this twice.
And you upload these data
collections, the marker walks,
up to Google servers, and then
we basically chew on them for
a little while, and we process
them so that we can deliver
this high-quality model.
Now, let's talk a little bit
about what we do next to
determine where the user is.
So really what happens-- and I'm
going to walk you through
the process.
We actually combine a lot of
different sensors to give you
that one estimate.
We use the Wi-Fi.
We use GPS.
We use the sensors, so that's
the accelerometer, the
gyroscope on your phone, the
barometer as well potentially.
But the truth of the matter,
when you come down to it, is
the one that we actually
dominate in a lot of these
calculations for absolute
position where you are within
the level is Wi-Fi.
And Wi-Fi has a lot
of problems when
you use it for location.
It really wasn't designed with
location in mind in any way.
And it's very, very sensitive,
especially it's very sensitive
to bags of water that happen to
be moving around, getting
in the way between the
APs and the signal.
And it just so happens that
humans are, more or less, bags
of water, at least as far
as Wi-Fi is concerned.
So you can imagine that at
really crowded venues like
this one where Wi-Fi is already
a challenge and you
have lots of bodies, Wi-Fi
isn't going to
behave in the same way.
And sometimes it can be
something really trivial, like
imagine that there's
big metal shutters.
They have a huge impact on the
way that Wi-Fi is perceived.
And the real issue is there's
this thing called RSSI, which
is the signal strength, and that
doesn't really give you a
good estimate of how far away
you are from the AP.
And then the other problem is
every phone measures Wi-Fi in
a slightly different way.
So you must be thinking, there
must be some other really good
reasons why Google chose to use
Wi-Fi for indoor location.
Not really.
There's only really one, and
that is that it's available
absolutely or pretty
much everywhere.
So many indoor venues have Wi-Fi
coverage that we can
actually do this indoor stuff,
and that's really its only
redeeming feature, to
be honest with you.
And so we thought that Indoor
is still compelling enough
that even though there are all
of these technical challenges
that we have to overcome and
it's not perfect, we still
think there's a lot of value,
and we can outperform GPS in
many situations.
So I want to walk you through.
Now that we've built these Wi-Fi
models, what does the
interaction between your phone
and Google servers look like?
And I want to emphasize that
this is, of course, anonymous.
It's not user specific
in any way.
And basically, what happens is
the first thing we check is,
do we have a high-quality
location model at this
particular venue?
If we do, we then determine if
you're indoors or outdoors.
And if we determine that you're
indoors, then we send
what's called a Level
Selector.
And the Level Selector--
say, we're here at Moscone..
There would be three levels
that you could be on, one,
two, or three, and it
would report, two.
And I think actually, Sarah
might have something she wants
to show us.
So let me just zoom that in.
SARAH PETERSON: So we spent a
little bit of quality time at
Moscone yesterday to
try and build out
some new indoor models.
And what you will see here,
this is where we are right
now, and it's actually pretty
accurate, I'd say.
I don't know if you guys can see
that, but we're actually
in a combination of rooms, 2010
and 2012, and it has them
right there.
So we're actually a little bit
flaky maybe, but this is what
we provide.
And if you're using this
throughout Moscone, we will
note it is a little bit flaky.
You may have noticed also that
the wireless here is
a little bit flaky.
They are moving, actually, all
around, and so you're not
going to get the ideal
indoor experience.
But definitely this is what
we're looking to provide, and
it works really, really well.
WALEED KADOUS: You'll also
notice that there was a blue
dot there that showed
the level.
So what will happen is when
you are at a venue and say
you're on the escalator, as you
go between floors, it will
automatically flip so that it's
always showing you what
current level that you're on.
So what you're seeing there,
that blue dot on the 2, that's
the output of the
Level Selector.
That's the thing that tells
you, am I on floor
one, two, or three?
So we send this little Level
Selector down to the phone,
and once the Level Selector on
the phone determines what
level you're on, we have this
other little component, this
level model, that captures the
Wi-Fi patterns that we saw
when we conducted that walk
through the building.
So now let's talk about the
other side of that, which is
what happens on the phone.
So as I mentioned before, we
do a lot of what we call
sensor fusion.
If GPS is available,
we'll mix it in.
But even when you do get GPS
indoor, it's subject to
something called multipath
reflections because the GPS
signal bounces around a lot.
So we have this stage called
sensor fusion that mixes the
accelerometer, the GPS, and
the Wi-Fi scan together.
So now that you have the Level
Selector on your phone and the
level model on your phone, you
do a Wi-Fi scan, and we run
the Wi-Fi scan through the Level
Selector and that tells
you which level that
you're on.
Once we've determined the level,
we then run the level
model for this level, so we
would have one level model for
each of the three different
floors of Moscone.
And that feeds into it
as an input to the
Sensor Fusion algorithm.
And that's what computes your
long and that's what appears
in Google Maps and soon through
the Fused Location
Provider that we mentioned
earlier.
So as you can see from here,
most of the computation's done
on the phone for that extra bit
of nimbleness and speed
instead of having a round
trip to the server.
And with that, I'd like to talk
a little bit about what
really excites us about the
future of Indoor Maps.
So right now, you can actually
experiment with Indoor Maps on
Google Maps Android API v2.
It shows the levels, it has the
Level Selector here, it
does the automatic floor
switching, and you can even
control the camera to get it to
look at the right things,
whatever it is that you're
interested in.
In addition, we're making
available, as part of the
announcement that Fused Location
Provider, there's a
component that's going to be in
Google Play services called
the Location Client, and that
will provide you the
high-quality latitude
and longitude.
We haven't surfaced the level
yet so we can't say you're on
Level Two of Moscone.
We're still working on that,
but it's coming.
So in the short term, this is
what we plan to work on.
It's this question of, can
we do more indoor venues?
And we're going to keep growing
them, and people are
uploading them to our servers
all the time.
It's really awesome.
We want to improve the quality
of the indoor location, and
that's going to happen through a
lot of different mechanisms.
One is technological, because
there are new technologies
coming along the way, like
Bluetooth Low Energy, and even
the humble Wi-Fi.
Finally, they're going to start
adding something called
802.11B, which gives you time of
flight, which gives you an
estimate of the distance.
So those new technologies that
come online, we're going to
mix them straight into that
sensor fusion process to give
you even higher-quality
location.
Not only that, but we can do
amazing things like you can
match against the map.
You can use the map to constrain
where people are to
get even higher accuracy.
And the thing that we're really
interested in is more
improvements for API
developments.
Now when it comes to the longer
term, this is what I'm
really excited about.
So clearly, we talked about
Google Maps and navigation and
those types of capabilities.
They're kind of awesome, but
there's something more.
Now, if you remember back to
what Larry said this morning
at the keynote, he mentioned
that it's really important
that we make smarter
applications.
And Amit talked about the
"Star Trek" computer.
So I have a question for you.
Would the "Star Trek" computer
be useful if it didn't have
floor plans of the Starship
Enterprise?
That's the question I want
you to think about.
If you are building contractual
apps that are
meant to be smarter, that look
out for information for the
user like Google Now for those
of you who have used Google
Now, how can you make those
applications work if you're
not really aware of where
people spend so
much of their time?
And I wanted to kind of show
you guys through the
applications we've kind
of been toying with.
This is not a launched
application.
It's just a demo app.
But what we did was
just for fun.
We built what we call
Friends in a Mall.
So we surveyed a big mall, and
then what we did is we just
had it so it would report
where people were.
And when we went out there
testing this, the engineers
were giggling.
We could imagine a lot of the
different applications people
could build.
Imagine you and your spouse
going to the shopping mall,
and he or she wants to buy
something, and you want to buy
something else, then
you can split up.
Imagine the opportunities here
for serendipitous encounters
when friends that you trust
that you've shared your
location with can appear on
the map, and you can just
catch up with them because you
found them by coincidence.
So this is one thing that
really made us feel that
indoor is kind of key to these
kind of contextual apps.
And the fast refresh rate, it
was just a really, really
compelling experience.
And the second thing was I want
to show you what we call
the invisible search term.
So let's say we're now
at Home Depot.
At Home Depot, imagine that
you're in the painting
department, and you search for
"painting." So do you expect
the Mona Lisa, or do you expect
to cover your wall with
icky yellow stuff?
If I'm in Home Depot, I know I
should be getting the second
search result.
But let's say you're in the de
Young Museum, which is also a
venue that we have indoor floor
plans for, and you do
the same search, exactly
the same term.
Don't you get exactly the
opposite search results?
So this is what we mean by using
indoor for contextual
applications, and this is what
I'm really excited to talk to
you about today.
And this is why task-oriented
applications, the conventional
question answering, yes, indoors
is useful for that.
But I want to see what you guys
as developers come up
with on this front.
So the key takeaways, before we
go on, is you know Google's
mission as well as we do--
organize the world's
information and make
it universally
accessible and useful.
But how can you do that if you
don't know about the place
where people spend so
much of their time?
It's a very active field.
We've launched three countries
in the last three months.
There's so much else going on,
and we're even making more
APIs available to developers.
And what I'm really excited to
talk to you about, what I
really think is the potential of
indoor, is these contextual
apps, and that's the question
I want to leave you with.
What are you going to do?
How can you use indoor
information to make the apps
that you guys deliver and make
available to your users even
more awesome?
So thank you very much.
A few quick pointers.
There's a Ground Truth talk.
I'm giving a talk about the
location side more tomorrow.
There's the Maps API v2 talks
and the Floor Plans Tool for
uploading as well as the Google
Maps Floor Plan Marker.
Thank you very much.
We look forward to
your questions.
[APPLAUSE]